hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich bin in der türkei und zwar
gerade in komplett es liegt bei side
zwischen antalya und alanya und ich
stehe neben absoluter den kennen
wahrscheinlich viele bereits aus dem
letzten jahr
denn ich war schon mal in diesem
restaurant im restaurant ki moon in
kunkel und wir haben letztes jahr
zusammen leckeres brot gebacken und
gewinn gemacht und da könnt ihr euch das
video gern noch mal anschauen ich
verlinke euch das um in der infobox und
heute habe ich mir den apfel muster
wieder zur hilfe genommen
denn wir machen heute eine richtig tolle
türkische spezialität die nennt sich die
kräfte also wortwörtlich übersetzt heißt
es ruhe frikadelle und zwar ist es
eigentlich ursprünglich aus ufa und der
ab donnerstag kommt ausfahrt deswegen
ist er da der spezialist und zeigt mir
heute wie das eben traditionell gemacht
wird die kräfte wird eigentlich mit rom
hackfleisch gemacht aber in der türkei
ist eigentlich auch schon gang und gäbe
dass man das nicht mehr so mit rogen
hackfleisch macht sondern eher
vegetarisch macht und im prinzip ist es
sogar eine vegane speisen denn wir haben
absolut keine tierischen produkte mit
drin und es ist eben auch für veganer
ganz gut geeignet es wird einfach aus
ruhiger gemacht und mit ein paar anderen
zutaten die zeige ich euch jetzt gleich
murat glaub ich ja schon welche ja dann
ordnen besatzung der gehört auch dazu
und ich würde jetzt sagen wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie man die g-kräfte
zubereitet dann bleibt jetzt dran ich
zeige euch jetzt nehme ich mal kurz die
zutaten an zutaten brauchen wir zwiebeln
die sind schon gestellt und fein gehackt
wir brauchen geriebene tomaten hier
haben wir ein gewürz das heißt also das
sage ich gleich noch was dazu
frühlingszwiebeln habe ich auch schon
fein geschnitten
hier etwas knoblauch auch schon fein
gehackt
etwas pfeffer salz hier haben wir kommen
also kreuzkümmel chiliflocken hier ist
olivenöl tomatenmark petersilie paprika
mark und fein gehackte frische minze und
zum servieren brauchen wir später so ein
paar salatblätter zu drohnen und ja das
gute zeit hier schön schon angerichtet
und hiermit die wichtigsten zutat ist
das bulgur und zwar der feine das steht
auch meistens stand drauf köpfte league
burgos und wir brauchen hier noch etwas
wasser und ein paar eiswürfel also
abdullah erklärt mit das letzte wie das
funktioniert und ich mach das jetzt für
euch denn ich habe das selber auch noch
nie gemacht dass sport für mich jetzt
auch heute premiere
jetzt kommen zuerst die zwiebeln
mitzumischen
dann auch die knoblauchzehen so ungefähr
30 bis 50 km tomatenmark ungefähr 30
gramm paprika man beides durch
juni in berlin
treffen
jetzt dafür
ok chiles
so ein esslöffel kommen ca 2 esslöffel
salz und jetzt kommt dort rein und zwar
ist es eigentlich auch chili und zwar
wird das vorher in tüten abgepackt und
unter die sonne gegeben
dann erhält es nämlich diese schwarze
farbe wenn ich das jetzt nicht bekommt
also normalerweise gibt es einen
türkischen supermärkten aber falls sie
das nicht bekommt weil es jetzt auch
nicht schlimm
das gibt dem ganzen eben nochmal der
intensiveren chili geschmack und aber
auch die farbe
dann drei kleinen geriebene tomaten
jetzt habe ich hier eiswürfel drin und
zwar in der türkei ja ziemlich heiß und
damit es eben nicht so schnell warm wird
dieser masse und nicht so schnell quält
gibt man eben eiswürfel mit dazu aber in
deutschland braucht man das eigentlich
nicht weil da reicht wenn ihr ganz
normales kaltes wasser nimmt das sind
dann das war jetzt so ungefähr sechs
eiswürfel also so ungefähr acht bis zehn
esslöffel wasser
also der apo nach uster hat jetzt schon
ein bisschen angefangen und zwar wird es
nicht einfach so geknetet sondern ihr
nehmt immer so einer hand runter geht
dann mit anderen darüber und müssten
ebenso durch heimen und es eben so lange
bis der bereich wird es dauert also
ungefähr 15 minuten
während es hier noch ein bisschen
arbeitet erzähle ich euch noch was über
das restaurant und zwar waren wir
letztes jahr auch im august und viele
meiner zuschauer waren und sogar nach
meinem urlaub hier und haben das
restaurant gefundenen kumpel
falls ihr es nicht findet und auch
herkommen wollten in der umgebung seid
also im side kumpel in manavgat könnt
ihr da auch anrufen da gibt es nämlich
ein pick up service und erholt euch dann
ab und zieht euch danach wieder heim und
ich finde es echt toll weil damit habe
nämlich dann uns eben erzählt hat dass
ganz viele da waren eben gesagt haben
wie sally potter und jetzt kommen sie
wegen mir und es fand ich echt richtig
schön und falls ihre umgebung sein
sollte die recht unbedingt mal
vorbeischauen weil hier gibt's richtig
tolles essen und freitagabend zur live
musik das sehen wir auch gerne da und
die samira teilnehmer auf der tanzfläche
also dafür muss er knetet jetzt glaube
ich schon so seit etwa zehn minuten und
man muss es jetzt auch wirklich 10 bis
20 minuten kneten also mindestens 15
und zwar bis sich das alles zu einer
masse verbunden hat als ich zeige euch
das mal hier
man sieht jetzt hier noch deutlich dass
man den bulgur hat noch einzeln erkennen
dass auch noch hart man kann auch jetzt
an der stelle schon mal abschmecken ob
salz und pfeffer stimmt ob die gewürze
stimmen
aber es muss halt so lang geknetet sein
bis sich das alles zu einer masse
verbunden hat und da können sie auch
immer wieder von diesem eiswasser da
drüben rausnehmen
von hier entweder eiswürfel oder einfach
normales wasser er taucht dann immer
wieder seine hand in wasser und knetet
dann schön weiter und der apfel heister
kehrte das jetzt einfach noch durch
mailings sagt bei dem wetter jetzt
gerade zu anstrengend und zu hause lasse
ich dann einfach den mut machen aber es
ist eine schöne arbeit also so zu
meditieren
also jetzt sieht man nach 15 minuten
schon dass es schon richtig schön
zusammenklebt also wie knete eigentlich
schon aber ein bisschen muss noch kneten
aber wenn später so ein paar kleine
stückchen drin bleiben ist es auch kein
problem
und dafür musste das geht natürlich auch
schneller wenn man ein bisschen warmes
wasser mit dazu gibt oder heißes wasser
das macht man nur traditionell nichts
mehr wenn man zu viel heißes wasser mit
dazu gibt am quell der der chor aufwies
und reich und wenn er eben einmal wie
sunrise aufgefallen ist entweder hat
nicht so dann erreichte diese konsistenz
mal krieg dieses klebrigen erzieherin
und es muss er klebt ich werde mal
wissen später zur kleinen frikadellen
formen wollen und deswegen lieber ein
bisschen länger kneten bisschen mehr
zeit lassen
also ich denke 20 minuten sind ganz gut
und dann hat man später ein schönes
endergebnis und schmeckt jetzt so
richtig gut
jetzt nach 20 minuten zeit geben wir das
ganze grün mit dazu also münze zu nehmen
wir jetzt die hälfte dann petersilie
wenn man auch die hälfte sind so
umgesetzt haben dann noch etwa vier bis
fünf klein geschnittene
frühlingszwiebeln und dann wird's weiter
geknetet wieder mit ein bisschen wasser
jetzt mal den tests
wenn die konsistenz gut ist bleibt seine
decke kleben
das wirklich gemacht
okay wer zu hause eine weiße decke hat
für diese aber nicht nachmachen
also wenn es sich gut ist dann klebt
auch nicht an der decke fällt
aber das ist perfekt also jetzt richten
wir das ganze an wir haben jetzt hier
schon mal täler frau gerichtet mit dem
salatblätter mit etwas kohlrabi und
zitrone pistole in die hand damit dann
eine große menge von dem teig jetzt
stecke ich mir hier so ungefähr war muss
gross ab drückt es in der faust und dann
hat es eben diese schöne form also diese
typische form abstechen nicht zu viel
uns drücken
unser pro person nimmt man an so
ungefähr acht bis zehn stück 8 für
normale etwa zehn für gute esser
und noch mehr für den rat
wir sind jetzt fertig wir machen jetzt
gleich noch die restlichen fertig aber
so sieht jetzt das endergebnis aus und
ich will das mal sagen der bucher darf
ist einfach gleich probieren
oder nehmen wir ein markanter übrigens
auch wenn ihr möchtet also dass ich ganz
gerne etwas granatapfel sirup dazu
reichen oder direkt mit in den teig
rhein geben und am besten ist man das
ganz frisch also oktober untersagt so
eine stunde maximal dann schmeckt eben
am besten aber ich weiß auch man kann es
schon so 1 bis 2 tage auch im
kühlschrank lagern wobei ich auch finde
dass es frisch am besten schmeckt vorbei
ist auch gerne am nächsten tag noch
essen
und wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt wie man
das ist am besten ihr euch die
salatblätter dann gebt ihr ein spiel
kräfte darauf also das fingerfood und
dann etwas zitrone und dann wird es so
direkt aus der hand gegessen
der modus ist scharf geworden er hat
wahrscheinlich nach meinen wünschen
gemacht und bisschen scharf gemacht das
heißt wenn ihr das nachmacht müsste
einfach die chili menge etwas reduzieren
und ihr könnt ihr während dessen immer
probieren und das abschmecken ist so ist
er zum glück kein rohes fleisch mit drin
auf jeden fall schreibe ich euch die
genauen mengenangaben noch mal auf
meinem blog blog de und freue mich dass
sie eingeschaltet habt und wenn ihr das
nach matschig schickt mir auf jeden fall
ein foto auf facebook oder instagram und
auf jeden fall besucht dieses restaurant
wenn ihr hier seid es ist einfach nur
toll
das ist einfach in kneten waltermann
und zuhause laster
katanha
wäre die straße
nee da mache jetzt wirklich er sperrt
die straße kann es sein dreharbeiten
bitte nicht durchfahren